dopo di loro
[Musica]
no stop di sam
io mi chiamo eddy ok non è proprio così
che ha forse devo prendere all'ananas
dietro c'è miopia che cazzo fatto ho
sentito la voce bluetooth perfetto
ragazzi spediti a casa il successo
cos'è successo dov'è finito il mouse
stimoli della birra certo è di
compiacere prenditela in faccia torniamo
indietro anche se non ho capito bene che
cosa sto andando a fare
[Musica]
fammi salire fammi salire se ce l'ho
fatta ma punk o la non è quello stronzo
di merda dov'è e lì io stavolta vado
dove dove voglio perché sono masochisti
ok era un [ __ ] porco cioè di oggi non
ci ho visto cosa è successo
[Musica]
giornata da qualche parte ci sono
ragazzi io io non lo so quante porte ci
sono ma entro in questo dio entra veloce
le nozze
oddio oddio che puro assurdo c'è una
freccia conficcata nel cervello ma sono
ancora vivo pedala pedala dai cazzo che
cola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quindi dovrei essere sicuri intorno
[Musica]
devono sollevare il cervello del
paziente mag addio
raga paranormal il cervello a qualcuno
di voi mi deve dare una spiegazione
scientifica a tutto questo
o mio dio santissimo ragazzo è qualcosa
di epico
guardate che lo zio cosa mio dio
raga non ci fa così kat
bene bene bene è grande non ci posso
credere
cosa sei frodo hai bisogno dell'anello
ho dimenticato da sotto per il settore
nel vulcano no veramente è l'anello
l'hai perso vai vai vai buttano porta
bolli cazzo buongiorno senta lei è
veramente sexy mimì può dire dove jason
o perché qua la gente non è molto
ospitale
almeno lei mi sembra un tipo molto
educato con un cazzo bye bye bye bye bye
bye si no
[Musica]
andiamo su boltro che ancora non ho
fatti mi serve sì andiamo con djalo
l'abito
voi ragazzi vi chiedete perché di essi
vi sono i miei personaggi preferiti c'è
un motivo perché al primo tentativo
io riesco a fare ste cose guardate
ancora una entrò nel guinness world
record ragazzi voglio la sessato jeans
record perché ogni [ __ ] boltro che
faccio vinca grandissimi una notiziona
finalmente era ora che succedesse
qualcosa di meno
era ora che succede maria sicari questa
vecchia donna che ha mangiato due che un
biscotto o mangiato l'ultimo biscotto ma
come si permette sta gente io che devi
muoverti veloce alza le braccia cosa
cazzo fai gli occhi
[Musica]
bello sto bagno fantastica si accende
anche l'acqua sporca [ __ ] cos'era
marco la testa non me lo aspettavo
ecco lo sapevo perché mi avete cambiato
ragazze la bandiera allora perdonati
voto raggiungere la bandiera vipre cos'è
sta roba
[Musica]
ap
le ragazze suoi vari per quali gente poi
conte sentito le mani
[Musica]
la lotta perché all'ultima donna
se ma vi rendete conto con 115 morti 115
morta moltissimo 116
[Musica]
proteggimi tuo amico porta tutta la
gioia che da quando ti muovi adesso
baiocchi cos'è cos'è oh mio dio
consacrato è successo grande gli occhi
il tuo compito e distrarmi la e di st
bye bye così michael snow york sei un
assassino di merda stanno facendo tutto
loro raga guardate oddio
ma è una cosa veramente
sexy
chi è che bisogna fare
[Musica]
perfetto ragazzi ci sono braccia voi non
fateci caso che a [ __ ] cos'era ce la
posso fare
dai mamma mia cioè non ci credo vai così
la bandiera la bandiera la bandiera la
bandiera maniera
[Musica]
i ragazzi non ci credo
fuori
cos'è sta roba mamma mia che sensi no
ragazzi questa è veramente una cosa più
sexy che io abbia mai fatto non mi
sentite attratti sessualmente da questo
assestamento
cos'è sta roba fin che la barca ma
[ __ ] allora ragazzi
ok adesso ufficialmente ok ha
ufficialmente stronzo ecco che cos'è non
ancora letti una stella un gesto
talmente bravo che è salito a stipic
abile
[Musica]
torniamo indietro e anche veloci oddio
chi è questo festival me lo fai vedere
che non sei un completi yacht ha almeno
un canestro almeno uno ma stiamo
scherzando
[Applauso]
c'è anche un pezzo hardware queste
perdona l'esploratrice lo faccio per te
allora devo riuscire a no ai sensi
sottospecie di frankestein mai riuscito
cosa dovrei fare dimmelo tu è che poi
c'è l'entrata dall altra parte magari
l'hai vista guardia montane lo sapevo
che la tematica ragazzi riguardo perché
c'è le corse sexy io non so come si deve
pagare
io sono più seguito è sentita coeli per
cosa ti credi l'altra chi parla guarda
che sa parlare
62 piaciuto dai che ci siamo a
rispondere a sto maledetto dov'è fermi
da datemi la cornetta maledizione pronto
chi no guardi io sono il famosissimo e
pluripremiato dottor pavi jazz permette
tra licei non mi risulta
devono è sbagliato numero